it is very cool to think that an
entirely new fan base is going to
discover 90210 tonight are you ready for
the fandemonium to get back into your
life it was hysteria the first time
around I'm ready let's do it yeah okay
well here's what I do know is that 90210
was an absolute pop culture a game
changer I went to the mall
to make an appearance and we didn't
figure that we would get a turnout of
5,000 people I had no idea that you know
we would require a SWAT team
I started getting grabbed and my clothes
could grab and pull
that's kind of scary they were hounded
they were like the Beatles I remember
being in a shopping mall on an escalator
and someone was screaming Donna I was
like the first time I realized like
people know who we are
Luke Perry and I did the parents in
Fresno California at the zoo we were
literally like scrunched to them we had
to leave right away and be taken out to
the parrot cage so
I was just in Spain and I found out that
we're very big over there also it's
incredible
got off the plane and there were about
5,000 people that were waiting to see me
I was like Luke Perry I'm not look at
the height of its success the teen drama
drew in over 21 million viewers a week
it was seen in 43 countries around the
world and generated billions of dollars
in merchandising revenue I used to play
with little dolls and I have been made
after this character Kelly so it's it's
pretty frightening actually did all that
without the help of social media well
Shannon had already found fame in the
cult classic Heather's Jason was
struggling sharing an apartment with an
up-and-coming actor named Brad Pitt and
Luke was working a construction job just
before he was cast man I was unemployed
for like 18 months working in a fish
store I just wanted to know at that time
when that first audition you know how am
i how am I gonna make my rent pay et was
on set when the show debuted in 1990 and
even though it wasn't an immediate hit
this cast knew it was only a matter of
time I think that the show can really
skyrocket and give the audience
something else to look at besides the
same old thing that they're watching
every Thursday night Dylan what if I'm
pregnant the tipping point was I think
when Brenda lost her virginity and then
from there it was so shell-shocked that
we went into summer episodes that was
also new original content while everyone
else was on hiatus gave people something
in a watch and the fact that we were
bringing content that had glitz and
glamour and kids having fun was just
very watchable it just made the show
skyrocket they just wish we could rewind
the last three years by the time the
show made its final bow in 2000 it had a
legion of diehard fans for life and
rumblings of a reboot even then oh if
they do do one though they can't wait
tour all like 50 that would that's not
their can I say
of course the show is gonna be
remembered on for mostly my hair I think
we were dealing with major issues that
young people would were going through
and our show sort of gave them a voice
and and was there for them and in its 10
years on the air a whole lot of now
famous guest stars popped up what what
your future husband say most attracted
him to you my mind it was the show that
I watched as a kid growing up that made
me want to move to LA from Ryan to
Fergie - Christina - Matthew Perry
before friends I've always see what
these clunkers are made up
no thanks Lucy Liu's first acting gig
Peach Pit waitress so what can I get you
today I work with both Luke Perry and
Jason Priestley so it was a thrill back
then especially since they were just
heartthrob
you know Eva Longoria bastogne got her
start as flight attendant number three
do you know mr. white goose is on the
flight the flight was completely full I
barely remember my name I did extra work
because they fed you I would steal fruit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]